Natalia pschenitzschneider weiß was
passiert wenn man nicht tut was das
System Putin verlangt sie war
verheiratet mit einem reichen russischen
Unternehmer bis 2018 lebte sie mit ihrem
Mann Valerie pschenichschny ein
unbeschwertes Leben
erfuhr auch sehr gerne Ski sogar auf
schwarzen Pisten
ihr Mann war ein erfolgreicher
Geschäftsmann auf dem Gebiet der
3D-Technik in Russland führend zusammen
mit seinem Sohn Denise hatte gut
laufende Firma aufgebaut
einen Auftrag vom
Verteidigungsministerium
er sollte 3D-Modelle erstellen und
produzieren
unsere Firma war darauf spezialisiert
originalgetreue Modelle von U-Booten mit
allen Details zu erstellen
ein millionenschwere Auftrag aus
öffentlichen Mitteln
eines Tages kamen fsb-agenten und
meinten sie haben einen guten Auftrag
über eine hohe Summe bekommen wie es in
unserem Land üblich ist muss ein Teil
davon als Provision an uns zurückfließen
am Anfang forderten sie 1,5 Millionen
Euro
wenig später wird der Unternehmer ohne
Vorwarnung vom russischen Geheimdienst
festgesetzt der Vorwurf Veruntreuung von
Staatsgeldern Sohn Denise vermutet dass
sich sein Vater geweigert hat den
Geheimdienst FSB zu bestechen
kurz nach der Festnahme teilen die
Behörden der Familie mit Valerie habe
sich in seiner Zelle erhängt doch die
Familie glaubt das nicht zu schwer sind
die Verletzungen am schenitschnießkörper
wer der Staatsmacht nicht gehorcht lebt
gefährlich das System Putin duldet keine
Widerrede
vor allem seit Beginn des Krieges in der
Ukraine steigt die Zahl verstorbener
Manager und Oligarchen auffällig an
wird in seiner Villa in Spanien erhängt
an einem Seil aufgefunden seine Frau und
Tochter sterben durch Stichverletzungen
Alexander sobottin vergiftet mit Kröten
Gift im Haus seines Schamanen
Alexander juliakow leitender
Angestellter des ölgiganten lucoil wird
erhängt aufgefunden
ravil maganov Chef des Unternehmens
lucall kommt unter ungeklärten Umständen
ums Leben
eine auffallend hohe Zahl ungewöhnlicher
Todesfälle
das System Putin
jedes Volk insbesondere das russische
Volk wird immer in der Lage sein wahre
Patrioten von Verrätern zu unterscheiden
es spuckt sie einfach aus wie eine
Fliege die in ihren Mund geworden ist
Russlands Oligarchen ihr Reichtum und
ihre Verschwendung sucht sind Sagen
umwoben Yachten Privatjets Luxusvillen
Roman abramowicz Spielzeug war lange
Zeit der englische Top-Club Chelsea
London doch sie alle hingen schon immer
von der Gunst des Kreml ab und vor allem
von Vladimir Putin
[Musik]
selbst ist das System und das System
heißt Putin Putin hat das ganze
konstruiert wir können heute eigentlich
nicht mal mehr vom Oligarchen in dem
Sinne sprechen wie er in den 90er Jahren
bezeichnet wurde es sind Putins
Oligarchen obwohl sie auch Eigentum
besitzen kommt ihr Reichtum nur aus dem
Staatshaushalt
2004 demonstriert Putin seine Macht dann
damals reichsten Mann Russlands in einem
Schauprozess verurteilt ein Gericht
Michael hodolkowski wegen
Steuerhinterziehung zu 9 Jahren
Lagerhaft er hatte die Opposition
unterstützt und nicht getan was der
Kreml wollte
danach haben die Oligarchen aufgehört
politischen Einfluss zu kaufen obwohl
das normales Lobbying wäre natürlich
darf man keine Parlamentarier direkt
bestechen aber Spenden von Unternehmen
an Parteien ist eine normale Praxis
in Russland läuft nach dem Fall oder
kowski alles über den Kreml die
Oligarchen sind entmachtet seit
Kriegsbeginn hat Putin die Zügel noch
straffer gezogen der Westen hat viele
Oligarchen mit Sanktionen belegt
Vermögenswerte eingefroren
einreisesperren verhängt
viele der Superreichen sind wieder
dauerhaft in Russland sind noch mehr
abhängig von Putins Gnaden der
Widerworte gibt wird bestraft der
industriemagnet der die Pasca
kritisierte den Krieg in der Ukraine und
war wenig später sein Luxushotel in
Sotschi los
Putin gibt Putin nimmt
in der russischen orthokratie
funktioniert es anders als normalerweise
hier gibt die Staatsmacht dir deinen
Besitz dein Besitzer kauf dir keine
macht
zurück bei Familie ciniti die
mittlerweile in Frankreich politisches
Asyl bekommen hat dass ihr Mann brutal
ums Leben kam macht Natalia fassungslos
[Musik]
war nichts kann so etwas rechtfertigen
wer ist zu so etwas fähig
das sind Tiere
in ihrer Heimat Russland werden sie
nicht zurückkehren zumindest nicht
solange sie im System Putin um ihr Leben
fürchten müssen